consider the following game even structs
Bob to go into a room Bob finds the room
empty except for some locks an empty box
and a single deck of cards Eve tells Bob
to select a card from the deck and hide
it as best he can
the rules are simple Bob cannot leave
the room with anything cards and keys
I'll stay in the room and he can put at
most one card in the box Eve agrees that
she has never seen the locks he wins the
game if Eve is unable to determine his
card so what is his best strategy well
Bob selected a card six of diamonds and
threw it in the box first he considered
the different types of locks maybe he
should lock the card in the box with the
key though she could pick lock so he
considers the combination lock the key
is on the back so if he locks it and
scratches it off it seems like the best
choice but suddenly he realizes the
problem the remaining cards on the table
leaked information about his choice
since it's now missing from the deck the
locks are a decoy shouldn't separate his
card from the deck he returns his card
to the deck but can't remember the
position of his card so he shuffles the
deck to randomize it shuffling is the
best log because it leaves no
information about his choice his card is
now equally likely to be any card in the
deck he can now leave the cards openly
in confidence
Bob wins the game because the best Eve
can do is simply guess as he is left no
information about his choice most
importantly even if we give Eve
unlimited computational power she can't
do any better than a guess this defines
what we call perfect secrecy on
September 1st 1945 29 year-old Claude
Shannon published a classified paper on
this idea Shannon gave the first
mathematical proof for how and why the
one-time pad is perfectly secret Shannon
thinks about encryption schemes in the
following way imagine Alice writes a
message to Bob 20 letters long this is
equivalent to picking one specific page
from the message space the message space
can be thought of as a complete
collection of all possible 20 letter
messages anything you can think of that
20 letters long is a page in this stack
next Alice applies a shared key which is
a list of 20 randomly generated shifts
between 1 and 26 the key space is the
complete collection of all possible
outcomes so generating a key is
equivalent to selecting a page from this
stack at random when she applies the
shifts to encrypt the message she ends
up with a ciphertext the ciphertext
space represents all possible results of
an encryption when she applies the key
it maps to a unique page in this stack
notice that the size of the message
space equals the size of the key space
equals the size of the ciphertext space
this defines what we call perfect
secrecy for if someone has access to a
page of ciphertext only the only thing
that they know is that every message is
equally likely so no amount of
computational power could ever help
improve a blind guess now the big
problem you're wondering with the
one-time pad is we have to share these
long keys in advance
to solve this problem we need to relax
our definition of secrecy by developing
a definition of pseudo randomness